[Musique]
/ efe
le mieux c'est de l'argent
[Musique]
le premier vendredi soir de
herbert cali commandé par mon personnage
Gilberto exulte
vraiment sur le point de réussir parce que
ils viennent de tuer leur ennemi
numéro qui était pour je cherche notre côté
l'ennemi est mort
c'est-à-dire entre
C'était des passes de ta crise de jardinier
gilberto rodriguezmiguel rodriguez
Miguel apparaît toujours comme le deuxième
la petite affiche derrière son frère
nous voulons livrer à chacun
de vous une participation juteuse de la
dernier décompte des revenus de cette année
son frère était le gars que le manager
peut faire face et niveler
gérer les comptes ici tout y est
c'est jusqu'au dernier centime monsieur
en 2003 avant in pacho herrera selon le
personnage qui y fait face
le temps d'être gay pour être l'un des
patrons d'un des cartels de la drogue
le plus puissant du monde il n'y avait pas de place
Pour un homme
Je me suis fait une bonne place il y avait
pas très flashy non plus
ce sont les mêmes qu'en mai
et maîtrise en traitement d'ingénierie de
le bébé
oh
Yo
[Musique]